besoin
5 4 3
alors bon soir bonjour à la planète et
si tu entames canada avec nous en studio
nos amis c'est l'équipe de rêve
il manque à peine une personne sur
quatre aujourd'hui quand je dis l'équipe
de rennes c'est parce que ça commence
avec elle marie bonjour stéphane nous
est prêtée par les services le service
espace autochtone de radio-canada oui
exactement
ancien collègue de travail de radio
canada international services français
servait espagnol aujourd'hui vous êtes
au secteur français c'est aujourd'hui
oui aujourd'hui trois langues
officielles au canada
les français espagnol s'est jamais 3
lanes samedi et ça va très bien très
content de vous avoir avec nous ça fait
trois quatre semaines on vous a pas vu
et en langue espagnole pas d'accord si
vous étiez perdu là bas maintenant du
côté de la de dudu de la technique on a
que coéquipiers aujourd'hui notre
collègue du secteur français est en
vacances jusqu'à là je ne vous dira pas
parce que les gens sur facebook qui
vérifient des adresses rien dire
c'est privé est en vacances jusqu'à la
fin de l'après midi voilà les eaux
gimeno bonjour bonjour monsieur servait
merci de me demander si ça va bien oui
ça va très bien fantastique
écoutez bon je demande pas souvent nous
allons aller au travail
[Musique]
moi j'ai vous aimez toujours c'est vrai
pour ça qu'on on a beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler ensemble à qatar aujourd'hui
je tousse voilà elle vous prêt pour le
gras la grande édition
vous n'avez aucune idée du sujet c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
on vous présente la vidéo 5 images dès
que vous pensez avoir la bonne réponse
vous soufflez le aboutit très fort pour
qu'on vous entende ce soit clair qu'il
ya dedans big 8 et c'est elle qui l'a
qui loupe dans votre cas ce sera soit
elle puisque ne peut pas jouer
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il répond je
fais
à peu près voilà alors tout se joue
entre paloma et moi cinq images vidéo on
regarde sa présence musicale sera bien
la prochaine fois que québec
trois anciens premiers ministres du
québec pour apprendre des choses et vous
c'est bon ça c'est la tour de radio
belles photos franchement là c'est
réussi
elle est là la renaissance du bleu la
couleur bloquer notre sujet lévesque
le journal dit ok oui à l'époque ce qui
est un réseau canadien
il était alors faite il était à il était
parti à la guerre de corée mais je sais
qu'il a commencé sa carrière à radio
canada international comme journaliste
on a toujours l'espoir d'aller vérifier
sur place
on est prêt pour l'allumage ici pas de
l'allumage mais d'éclairage méprenne pas
ce que nous on est déjà à lui mais pas
si c'est vrai bouhila louis le jeu de la
grosse boule première manche coup de
boule coup de boule en cette fin de
semaine de sakher nom va vous jouer un
bon début beaucoup ici c'est bon pour 20
points d'accord vous avez fait
d'infirmation il ya un instant va
vérifier et rené lévesque avait 14 ans
lorsqu'il a décroché un emploi d'été
comme traducteur annonceurs lecteur de
nouvelles à la radio à newcastle son
petit village natal a dit vous avez
raison
oui je trompé de palinges un peu trop à
19 ans il a travaillé dans une station
de québec
la station radio a commencé chaîne voici
la question dite moi vrai ou faux vaut
pour 20 points
vous pouvez jouer gagnant l'an passé où
radio canada international laquelle des
deux organisations a été la première à
lui offrir un poste de journaliste pour
couvrir la scène internationale bella
tombe étant la mèche crouch croyez que
c'était radio canada international mais
vous commencez à me faire douter nous
parlait des derniers mais lui il était
bilingue à l'international oui c'est ce
que je dis aussi maintenant donc je suis
obligé de vous accorder les informations
dont on dispose ce qu'il a été un beau
chic d'abord qu'ils cherchaient des
journées est bilingue à voir mais il
était tout jeune alors oui extrême 20
juin
et puis est ensuite il est arrivé en 46
à ercis voilà la bonne avec l âge est ce
que c'est attendez voir et emmenés en
quelle année on va 22 202 j'allais
certain non plus que ça démarre à 65 ans
il est marrant 87
voilà c'est trop compliqué il avait 24
il avait 24 ans il est meilleur en 24 en
1946 il a été embauché par ercis donc il
avait lavé 24 ans jean calais nord 22 c
5 2 1 il avait 24 ans il est né en plein
2 enfin j'espère que c'est on décrit
bien la réalité on n'est pas comme trump
on n'invente pas les choses ici on va se
tourner vers quelqu'un qui le connaît
bien
ah oui alors il et nous attend sur ce
cas il s'agit de yannick des biens il
est le coordinateur de l'espace rené
lévesque
sorte de musée extérieur intérieur où on
peut découvrir non seulement le
l'histoire politique de cet homme là
mais sa jeunesse son enfance et en
gaspésie ce cas là on va le demander
monsieur des billets bonjour bonjour
quand vous l'avez vu on sait pas
grand-chose mais d'accord le même quand
même
il est effectivement né en 1922 à senna
qu'elle coince à new carlisle dans la
baie des chaleurs en gaspésie au coin
puis est ce que c'est vraiment un
endroit chaud particulièrement l'été au
niveau du tourisme
oui absolument il ya beaucoup de
touristes dans le retour de la péninsule
au complet et donc dans la
baie-des-chaleurs également bon pendant
qu'on se parle on va va jouer sans son
on pourrait le faire là on pourrait
faire un bon premier pas laisser ça
c'est rené lévesque le soir de je pense
de sa victoire
écoutez bien les enfants 1976 d'accord
pas 1946 1976
on va je veux laisser jouer pendant une
minute et après ça on en parle à notre
invité c'est déjà fini
on l'a chaudement applaudi ce soir alors
là il ya l'histoire politique
les québécois les canadiens la
connaissent bien nous on s'adresse à des
gens qui sont à l'extérieur en grande
partie à l'extérieur qui sont en france
ai-je entendu parler du mouvement
souveraineté-association quand on va au
musée
quelle est la tournure politique de
l'exposition à quoi ça ressemble si je
suis par exemple un fédéraliste est ce
que je vais aimer me promener au musée
en fait c'est probable c'est probable
parce qu'on fait vraiment le tour de la
vie de monsieur lévesque de son enfance
jusqu'à la fin de son parcours politique
et monsieur lévesque après beaucoup de
chemin avant le mouvement souveraineté
association dont étaient partie prenante
la révolution tranquille avec le parti
libéral à l'époque donc il c'est une
exposition qui est vraiment sur l'homme
son parcours et l'impact qu'il a eu sur
les québécois donc tous les québécois
même on voit des gens qui n'étaient pas
d'accord du tout politiquement avec lui
mais qu'il respectait quand même au plus
haut point
pour ce qui l'avait amené au temps comme
communicateur à l'époque où il est
journaliste au niveau politique ce qui
est phénoménal avec cet homme-là c'est
que c'était la politique dans twitter
même si on n'aimait pas l'homme il était
attachant moi dans ma famille il y avait
la moitié qu'il détestait enfin
détestait son option politique pas lui
mais personne ne pouvait le détester il
avait quelque chose dans son regard une
humilité je pense qu'ils étaient
désarmante effectivement une humilité y
était proche des gens réellement proche
des gens et pouvait aussi être proche
des gens sans avoir un discours qui
tombait dans un populisme ou encore en
utilisant un langage plus populaire
était quand même très éloquent avec un
langage très soutenue mais réussissait
tout de même à être proche des gens à
travers ce type de communication quand
les gens visitent votre musée on va voir
des images à l'instant s'il s'agit ici
pour notre langage technique vidéo
numéro 38 bloqué 38 des autres une année
une vidéo par année et puis de vie comme
ça t on voit des images de votre musée
et puis je vous jouerais peut-être ma
question quand les gens visitent
qu'est-ce qui les surprend le plus alors
esquivé surprend le plus premièrement
c'est que le gros de notre exposition
c'est à l'extérieur
donc quand on parle d'un musée on peut
parler d'un musée jardin
il ya un côté et florales aussi végétale
de deere company 2 to avec la vue sur la
baie des chaleurs
l'option c'est la première surprise que
les gens ont mais je dirais que le fait
que je dirais qu une des plus grandes
surprises à travers l'exposition c'est
que le parcours de monsieur les vents
qui est passé par l'armée américaine et
non par l'armée canadienne n'a quand
elle était correspondant de guerre à la
deuxième guerre mondiale donc c'est
peut-être ce qui surprend le plus des
gens à prime abord il ya quand même
encore des gens qui sont surpris qu'ils
aient beaucoup de choses à l'époque où
il était un parti libéral des gens qui
ne savaient simplement
donc c'est aussi ça sur prague où l'ag
on entre on entre aperçu la statue de
rené les vins qui se trouve devant le
musée qui était je pense avant ça
quelque part à l'assemblée nationale du
québec
effectivement c'est une statue qui
avaient été faites un bronze qui avait
été fait pour représenter monsieur
lévesque à la fable et national et puis
à la demande de corinne sa deuxième
épouse il avait été fait grandeur nature
donc à travers les autres bronze qui
était une fois et demie la grandeur des
hommes politiques
eh bien ça faisait quand même
relativement petit ce qui fait qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes qui n'ont pas
apprécié qu'ils ont même jus
potentiellement de mauvaises intentions
alors que c'était pas le cas cette
statue doit donc été remplacé par un
bras
2.5 fois la grandeur de monsieur
lévesque et celle là a été rapatrié à
new carlisle part à ce grand homme était
effectivement petit but nous a dévoilé
la méthode le fond de l'histoire à
quelle hauteur exactement jean petit
j'ai 500 piétons se rabattre au maître
61.5 pièce à côté ahmed 65 regarder des
gens grandeur nature à côté d'une
version c'est la version saas et sa
grandeur sa véritable grandeur où ça va
rendre la grandit c'est le contenu car
c'est un graveur au quai paquet il
n'était pas sur le piédestal on pouvait
lui mettre des choses sur la tête se
pouvait traiter un nom mais je pense non
j'ai passé choisi fasse penser comme ça
que ça se passe
1 déjà fait leur statut a toujours vu le
piédestal a un peu monté sous le pied
des stages et vue légèrement sur les
pieds destin qui aurait pu faire des
blagues c'est ça écoutez faut pas
encourager des gens qui nous écoutent à
faire ce nom c'est validé l'idée
l'idée c'était d'annoncer que cette
initiative que vous menez au niveau d'un
musée intérieur extérieur
ça fait longtemps que ça se travaille
soit 5 ans rappellent des premiers
reportages effectués par rci même là
dessus 1 nos collègues adrien h ans
avait fait une entrevue avec l'un de vos
collègues est là et c'est arrivé à
maturité ça vient d'ouvrir
c'est au mois de juin où jamais on est
ouvert au public le 8 juin tant que ça
fait à peine plus d'un mois qu'on est
maintenant en opération on a beaucoup de
gens qui viennent d'éditer les gens sont
très heureux autant des installations et
du contenu qu'on peut retrouver parce
que c'est quand même une visite les ya
plus d'une heure de contenu audio
donnant la visite audioguidée à
l'extérieur avec l'ehpad ou sans compter
le ce qu'on peut faire à l'intérieur
dont un court métrage également qu
est-ce qu il n'y a que des visiteurs
québécois aux canadiens qu'ils viennent
voir est ce que les visiteurs étrangers
sont curieux de savoir qui ils étaient
ce qu'ils le connaissent
on a eu quelques européens des gens et
notamment une japonaise fait thèse sur
un élève est effectivement la plupart
des gens particulièrement non parce
qu'on est au début aussi sont déjà
les gens du québec en général mais on
sait que la saison touristique en
gaspésie mais beaucoup plus d'européens
jean d'étrangers en fin de thèse et
comment ça se fait que ça a pris tant de
temps avant que ce musée ouvre parce
qu'il est quand même mort depuis 1987
bon il ya eu l'initiative ici c'est la
fondation de la maison rené lévesque qui
n'a lancé l'idée originale était de
racheter la maison où monsieur lévesque
a grandi pour en faire de musique
suite à différents des les difficultés
ça n'a pas été possible donc ils se sont
tournés vers un nouvel espace qui a été
créé ça a évidemment donné des délais
supplémentaires
par contre laisser commencer en 2009
donc avant ce ces événements alors je ne
sais pas s'il y avait eu des tentatives
de faire un musée d'accord on refait le
rejouer les images du musée nous on a un
budget limité donc on ne fait que plus
vingtaine une 30 savent pas paloma vous
l'avez pas connu cet homme vous étiez
ailleurs dans un autre monde et vous
êtes si à peine n'est évidemment
exactement j'avais 10 ans quand il est
décédé donc j'ai déballé mano donc non
j'ai pas eu la chance de les connaître
mais en fait je les connais je les
connais j'ai l'impression de connaître
les verts oui parce que ça fait quand
même vingt ans que j'habite au québec
je suis québécoise donc je connais
l'histoire aurait pas au grand complet
mais toi mais qu'il m'appartient aussi
d'une certaine manière est ce que vous
avez une question par rapport à ces
soirées
mais je voulais a fait savoir s'il n'y
avait pas d'autres sites à travers le
québec où on fait hommage de cet homme
là si c'est la première fois qu'en ce
qu'on lui rend hommage de cette manière
il ya quelques autres endroits mais manu
quand là il ya un endroit où il y avait
une petite exposition qui était fait des
gens par contre ce sont des endroits
privés avec des choix des objets qui ont
appartenu à la famille lévesque ou
encore des têtes cette exposition qui
ont été montés par des propriétaires
d'entreprises
ici c'est vraiment un lieu un peu plus
officiel si on veut donc en partenariat
avec les différents gouvernements
la municipalité ici la statue a été
rapatriée d'ailleurs devant l'espace
rené lévesque
donc ça ça devient un peu un retour chez
lui
est-ce que des documents inédits qui ne
sont pas disponibles nulle part ailleurs
que vous vous avez entre vos mains
effectivement d'abord notre court
métrage qu'on présente ça c'est un court
métrage qui a été réalisée
spécifiquement pour l'espace ici et on a
énormément darchy sans être
nécessairement inédites parce
qu'effectivement la plupart des archives
que nous avons viennent des archives de
radio-canada qui était directeur était
d'une très grande contribution par
ailleurs donc sur les pas nécessairement
inédit ne se sont pas des contenus qu'on
retrouve facilement à l'externe
une dernière question une dernière
question rené lévesque a été donc élevée
en gaspésie la communauté autochtone en
gaspésie ce sont les micmacs quelle
relation il avait rené lévesque avec les
autochtones et particulièrement ceux de
gaspésie les micmacs alors c'est qu'il
ya eu des bons il ya eu des hauts et des
bas comme à peu près tous les chefs de
gouvernement des relations avec des
autochtones mais quand même des moments
assez importants dont une construction
d'hôpital dans une réserve jour norton à
l'époque la relation avec les micmacs je
pense pas qu'il a eu beaucoup de
relations dans sa jeunesse avec les
micmacs parce qu'ils sont plus dans
l'ouest de la baie des chaleurs
ici à new carlisle c'était beaucoup plus
belle des descendants britanniques ou
encore les irlandais avec qui il a
grandi puis monsieur devient une
question prime maintenant c'est moi
paloma qui vous la pose en fait j'étais
un peu inspirée par un mari qui a
demandé par rapport aux peuples
autochtones mais moi je me devais me
demander quelle était la relation de
monsieur lévesque avec les nouveaux
arrivants au canada au québec parce qu
il m a en effet fait justement la thèse
dont je parlais de l'étudiante japonaise
c'est sa porte sur ce sujet là parce
qu'elle prouve que celle à peu près le
seul politicien nationaliste qui est
resté ouvert sur le monde ont ouvert à
l'immigration ouvert aux autres cultures
de son parcours il a toujours été
démocrate avant d'être nationaliste et
il l'a toujours vraiment eu de
considération pour les cultures et même
pour la langue anglaise alors que
plusieurs lui prête des intentions
peut-être antilles anglophones c'était
pas du tout le cas
il voulait une primauté du français
souhaitaient quand même que les gens
puissent
primé leur culture je pense que les
anglophones le reconnaissent qu'il
n'était pas un anti anglophones ne
s'était pas une idée c'était d'être pro
à pro à faire dans les mains des
francophones après des décennies où les
affaires étaient dans les mains des
anglophones c'était son combat lui de
ramener sa dent dans les mains de ceux
qui qui de la majorité de partager un
meilleur partage écoutez c'est fascinant
une histoire fascinante puis c'est
quelque chose qu'on est en fait une
place où aller ou allez en parler ou à à
échanger là dessus je pense que ça
dépasse l'entendement que cet homme là
qui va passer à l'histoire comme étant
l'une des ressources les plus précieuses
ressources humaines les plus précieuses
au niveau politique n'est pas eu encore
sa place franchement ça me dépasse
mais je suis là je me sens mieux mais
l'initiative on est très heureux de
pouvoir accueillir les gens puis leur
faire découvrir le parcours de ce grand
homme non seulement politiques mais ce
grand québécois
alors monsieur yannick heude et bien
merci beaucoup de nous allons apporter
tout ça aujourd'hui à la table
merci merci à vous au revoir au revoir
c'était le coordinateur de l'espace rené
lévesque dans la région n'ont pas de
newcastle dans la baie des chaleurs
voilà que c'est beau enfin oui ben oui
j'ai travaillé en gaspésie pour radio
canada alors j'ai fait le tour de la
gaspésie bien des fois puis vraiment
quelle belle région surtout la baie des
chaleurs sait plus d'où le nom
amérindien ne devait pas être la baie
des chaleurs
non mais là quel était le nom amérindien
non écoutés il fait trop chaud ici un
studio allons sur la fraîcheur
écoutez j'ai quelque chose en parler des
archives dont ils disposent là bas c'est
grâce à radio canada en bonne partie
qu'on a ça et moi j'ai mis la main sur
dheune archives très précieuse oui je
pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de gens
qu'il l'ait vu j'ai concocté j'ai
fabriqué cette vidéo elle à un moment
donné
numéro 3
qui est normalement la 38 b 60 18 mais
là c'est la 3 aucun accord et c'est rené
lévesque là comme il n'y a pas de numéro
j'espère que ce soit la bonne oui
l'envoyer didier dheedene c'est la bonne
c'est sûr avec la grosse dan voinea 1951
il était aux 18 35 55 importe quoi là il
a été embauché à 51 par la télévision et
en 55 il parlait des années quand on
écoute les dindes qui forme
las en les plaçant je n'ai pas de son
nom les dindes blues un découvert
l'amérique n'est pas habitué autant que
les autres alors à des vérifications et
vivante environ mais un évident derrière
les dépouilles parce qu'ils aient
retrouvé travail alors que des tensions
je veux dire par exemple qu'il interagit
à wissant cannibales et centre a aussi
attiré maussade ils vont servant à
l'arrosage est saine entre nous je peux
vous décourager c'est un drôle d'animal
choisi comique si c'est difficile à
élever pompes et je veux dire à demander
des soins bien particulier attributions
venues de nos jours on a eu affaire où
link est bien balancé à et les mains
d'un loser est up qu'on a pas d'erreur
on a beau avoir des belles bêtes comme
ceux que vous avez piloté par le nude
enfin nous allons avoir la chair la
consommation pour ça est-ce que vous
comment vous feriez oui nourrir vous
saouler sélectionner les appelle la
sélection pas à faire pendant des années
qu'on a parvenu à avoir cet ère derrière
vous choisissez j'en conviens à
plaisançoise utilisant les dépositaires
au rabais
selon moi la réponse est non
grâce à la deuxième
vous avez invité à goûter le modèle
vivant de notre table à l'atteinte de
rené vexe jour en 1955
on parle lui de lui comme étant
politicienne sérieux amusant mais là
c'était et tout est sujet qu'il avait à
couvrir
z'imaginez écouter on est prêts pour
notre deuxième jeu de la grosse foule
on va avoir besoin d'éclairage un peu
spécial oui alors c'est bon pour combien
de points cette deuxième manche
30 voilà alors je vous accorde des
trains de pointe où les anglais où on
prendra pas avantage alors voici
vraiment la question de la grosse boule
2e 2e manche
rené lévesque à crédit la notion de la
souveraineté-association au niveau
politique l'a donc la vision d'un québec
indépendant mais associé économiquement
au canada dans le cadre d'une nouvelle
union semblable à ce qu'on a on connaît
à la communauté économique européenne
alors c'est la formule de la suivante
association bien connue des québécois
dit moi en quelle année est née cette
stratégie de la souveraineté association
en quelle année
oh la la celui qui est le plus proche de
la bonne réponse bien sûr importe les 30
points
lol donc la vie politique de cet homme
là disons c'est au tour de 1960 jusqu'à
son décès en 1987 en quelle année 77 77
vous dites donc après le premier
référendum
après le premier offrant d'hommes
soixantaine d'associations
il a eu l'idée
[Rires]
c'est ce que j'allais dire 72 c'est à
dire 74 l'année de mon arrivée au canada
on a chacun une prise ou trop tard vous
pouvez changer 68 68 eur 19 novembre
1967 il fonde le mouvement suivante
association il présente cette idée
politique 60 60 67
voilà écoutez j'ai voulais vous
présenter maintenant un bois bout de sa
vie du de son de début de sa vie
politique
quatre ans avant 1967 avant qu'il y
penser il faisait partie du parti
libéral du canada avant qui créé son
parti politique
il faisait partie de la majorité du
parti libéral qui est arrivé au pouvoir
après des années de noirceur celle de
maurice duplessis on peut en dire
beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui puisqu'il
est décédé depuis longtemps et parce que
c'était va aussi hans ethnie soir qu'on
parle de la grande noirceur de cette
époque où les politiciens faisait à peu
près tout ce qu'il voulait sur twitter
son sujet pas sûr qu'on sort soudain sur
twitter ouais ouais
alors voici sérieusement vidéo 5 1 oui
cela il ne ministre des ressources
hydrauliques
oui mais on va du son en prime écoutez
bien les ministres des ressources
hydrauliques qui va avoir
il veut que les québécois posté à venir
il y est quand même ailleurs il est dans
l'emploi parents l'enfant du sol vie des
récoltes mais dans l'emploi comprend des
gones de richesses industrielles qui
sont les grandes richesses primaire d'un
peu de d'un territoire comme le nom
d'après l'eau les mines et ça c'est des
choses qu'on contrôle l'endroit qu'on en
fera nous fera un avenir où ben n'ouvre
une espèce de croupissement médiocrité
comme des spectateurs qui regardent ce
qui se passe chez eux mais qu'ils
participants et ça ça appartient
ça appartient pas
complètement suffi décidé que
raisonnablement enfin y avoir pensé mais
décider que c'est nous qui décidons
justement mais toutes façons concept de
fabriquer des littéralement des épaves
prédestiné à était pas un peu plus leur
vie c'est possible qu'on appelle faire
sur ces servir de ce qu'on a qu'on sait
c'est aussi d'être des spectateurs de ce
qui se passe chez nos points de vue
économique
pis ce qui se passe chez nos points de
vue économique au point de vue technique
si on n'y est pas si on participe appui
aux besoins il va falloir participer
c'est pas la fin du monde tous les états
forts fédéral les faits c'est notre pays
participe l'état sur les moyens
autrement si je crois pas qu'on ait les
moyens souvent autrement
alors voilà c'était c1 ça résonne et on
le sent convaincu c'est pas c'est pas du
jeu politique la cc de l'affirmation qui
viennent de l'intérieur est maître chez
nous c'est le slogan je pense à un
moment donné qu'il les détails mais
chapeau nouveau l'histoire mais je
connais rien 300 où ça nous mène à la
défaite du référendum premier référendum
en 1980 on va regarder c'est la vidéo la
plus connue de cet homme là autant pour
les québécois que pour les canadiens
peut-être qu'à l'étranger
ils s'en souviendront six ont 40 ans un
peu comme certains parmi nous ici autour
de la table 1980 c'est d'ailleurs la
première fois de ma vie que je votais et
j'ai voté pour
évidemment ce référendum c'est plus sage
est court et coûter on regarde 1980 des
fêtes
s'il vous plaît
chaque année
[Musique]
si g
si si j'ai bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que ça se passait le soir
c'est un 15 novembre 1980 une date qui
résonne dans l'histoire du québec un peu
comme le 11 septembre 2001 fait partie
des choses or on sait où on est et où on
n'était pas encore en fait ce qui
voulait dire c'est si j'ai bien compris
vous me dites à la prochaine fois en
1995 mais il était plus là on nous
accusait celui là mais il a compris que
ça ne se passerait pas cette première
fois la deuxième devra aussi notre sur
le jeu de la grosse boule c'est un peu
triste
d'accord on aimait ça prend quand même
des éclairages on rit pas alors voici
grosse boule troisième question 50
points oui d'accord le 20 mai 1980 mais
non c'était pas le 15 novembre 15
novembre c'était la date où il t'arrive
au pouvoir en 960 et sesat en touche
parler du 1er fraudeur il est arrivé au
pouvoir en 76 premier référendum en 80
et il avec l âge 1922 compte 180 il a 58
ans lorsqu'il a perdu son premier mandat
mais voici la question
rené lévesque a essuyé une défaite
personnelle majeur mais quel était le
pourcentage du vote le non a obtenu
combien 300 mètres non indépendance oui
contre combien pour le oui
45 pour le nom 55 pour le sait moins que
ça
alors vous vous dites c'est 50 de
quelque chose comme ça sur les 52 pour
le non et non pas cinq ans manon a oui
ok c'est vrai que je suis dans la
version wii sort était donc 55 ans et
non 40 la semaine prochaine afin d une
chance mathématique
[Rires]
moi je dirais je vais aller c'était
justement l'un s'était pas les votes
ethniques annonce à temps
là on était à 51 % c'est ça je contre
leur est fait contre eux c'est ça que je
oui mais là n'est pas la question
donc on est à 1 84 c'est plus que ça
c'est 56 5
j'avais 10 55
alors écoutez qui quels sont les pour ça
qu'elle son livre combien de points vous
avez jusqu'à maintenant 0 à moi et là 0l
mais n'ont jamais dit rené lévesque est
ce qu on peut noter que 30 c'est long
c'est ça d'accord 0 comme davin 30
d'accor la bonne réponse
quality qui est le plus proche 55 26
pour cent cinquante six mois je ne sais
pas si vous avez 50 points donc ils
assoient gagne toujours
écoutez on bat jeudi à l'ats prochain on
vous accorde également 50 safest qui est
le gagnant ou la gagnante s'est accordé
cinq ans pointe à lcl mais à vous aussi
non moi j'en avais vingt cinq ans et 70
la veille elle a lavé train moi c'est
comme les olympiques tout le monde gagne
c'est fini les belles histoires
je vais vous présenter la dernière vidéo
d'accord encore quelque chose que je
pense que beaucoup de gens n'ont pas vu
moi j'ai découvert ça l'automne dernier
j'ai fait un reportage qui s'appelait
les cinq métiers de rené lévesque savait
donc le journaliste le ministre et
l'indépendantiste le perdant est le
retraité c'est des métiers tout ça voici
ce que ça donne deux jours avant sa mort
il rencontre son adversaire politique
monsieur trudeau pierre elliott trudeau
qui n'était plus lui même premier
ministre canada mais les deux s'étaient
affrontés énormément on était
fédéraliste
mathis est le seul évêque est allé à la
librairie à montréal où monsieur trudeau
signa une autobiographie quelque chose
mais bien un nouveau livre dix jours
avant la mort de renée lévesque d'une
crise cardiaque à sa maison voici les
changes entre les deux politiciens sa
demeure très civile très civilisée très
très agréable
[Musique]
[Rires]
faire
[Musique]
dommage on n'entendait pas de quoi ils
parlaient l'anglais mais la mort l'a
vraiment pris par surprise
il avait l'air ambiant mais c'est un
très gros fumeur oui toujours à la
bouche c'est ça qui vient apporter
qu'est ce que ce n'était pas sa première
ils ont fait une autopsie découvert
qu'il avait eu d'autres des crises
cardiaques wii qui n'avait pas au
problème en été effecté oui puis
aujourd'hui leur éclat je pense qu'il
nous l'a 1922 on est tandis qu'il y
aurait 80 il avait 96 quand il est
décédé quand il est décédé j'étais en
voyage en israël et en fait j'ai appris
comme deux semaines plus tard qu'il
était décédé ont là-bas en israël je
disais pas le journal jeu des feux se
savent pas lire les bruits donc à
twitter n'existait pas en 87 mais
j'avoue que ça avait été un choc
vraiment une grande surprise d'apprendre
son décès toute une surprise comme pour
beaucoup de québécois d'ailleurs à
l'époque à juin dernier commentaire non
non ce que je venais quand j'ai écouté
la semaine prochaine mon jeu je viens en
vacances j'ai travaillé tout pendant
deux ans sans prendre de haut
je voulais demander pourquoi on a parlé
des rennais l'évêque aujourd'hui y at il
eu l'accord de l'ouverture du sas et la
moitié se trouve à l'extérieur donc en
plein hiver d'imaginer visiter son nom
la scène en france et en galilée là non
remarquez que je pourrais y aller et
brand a par la suite or chez perçu et si
vous faites ça enfin skype
situé au pas dans mes vacances je ne
peux pas m'appeler durant mes vacances
est connue csu dérangerait pas de le
faire pour les copains ici au travail
vous et vous donc la semaine prochaine
d'un retour à la normale il y aura plus
de folien ce repos pour tous c'est ça
exactement
merci stéphane merci vous prenez des
vacances aussi
oui bientôt ne dit pas parce que je
savais facebook tout le monde c'est vrai
moi je reste à la maison
alors ces jours je vais partir pigeot je
veux m'acheter un chien ou de je pense
d'aider des chiens bergers allemands
pour surveiller la maison parce que je
suis je m'achète cherche une carabine
d'autres jours si on les bat y aller
mais les malfaiteurs maintenant alors
des armes à feu je pourrais vous
raconter des histoires de gens qui m'ont
côtoyé avec des armes à feu le gers et
policiers dans un drôle d'entourage
finale non mais effectivement je
pourrais vous raconter des belles
peut-être que je le ferai bientôt
retourner vos vacances faits sont une
émission pour une histoire sur la chasse
sur la charge par ce centre aideront
pour en parler des armes à feu dans ma
vie finie la comédie on a assez parlé à
marie merci toujours de nous prêter vos
services alors que certains c'est un
certain ben oui c'est ça c'est un moment
où on n'est pas obligé d'être trop
sérieux vers les chambres
paloma martinez merci beaucoup
elle continue à travailler avec nous
durant tout l'été leonardo gimeno
fantastique pour votre travail vous
faites le travail de trois ou quatre
personnes puis 4 1 c'est quelque chose
très apprécié alors bon été on se tourne
vers une caméra en main pour saluer
les deux sens entre 1000 et 2000
[Rires]